مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا
[موسيقى]
ظهور رونالدو بالزي السعودي طبعا الكل
بيعرف انه صفقه رونالدو هي مش صفقه رياضيه
لا هي صفقه رياضيه والى جانب ذلك في اهداف
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وثقافيه وما الى ذلك
من اموره ولكن لبس الزي السعودي امبارح
كان له مدلولات نعم اكيد اقتصاديه وثقافيه
لجذب النجوم وما الى ذلك ولكن بنفس الوقت
كان في رساله مهمه جدا والرساله هاي تكمن
بانه رونالدو سعيد رونالدو قادر ينخرط
بالمجتمع السعودي
رونالدو قادر يكون جزء من الكيان او
المزيييك اللي موجود بالسعوديه وهذا امر
بخلي بقيه اللاعبين اللي حابين او عم
يفكروا بموضوع الانتقال الى السعوديه
يتشجعوا لانه شايفين انه رونالدو نجح
بالانسجام وخصوصا بظل التغير اللي عم يصير
بالسعوديه والانتقال من المرحله الى مرحله
اخرى على الصعيد الاجتماعي ففي صوره معينه
موجوده عند الاوروبيين تحديدا حول اسلوب
الحياه في السعوديه وهي كانت صوره واقعيه
الى فتره طويله من الزمن عم تتغير بشكل
تدريجي فلما يشوفوا رونالدو سعيد بالمجتمع
السعودي ولابس السعودي وعم يشرب القهوه
العربيه ويؤدي رقصه العرضه اللي شفناها
راح يكون في حاله من التشجيع على انضمام
هؤلاء اللاعبين ايضا للدوري السعودي
واللاعب بالسعوديه والعيش ايضا بالسعوديه
متل ما بنعرف انه اللاعبين كمان بيتاثروا
بعائلاتهم وبالتالي الجانب الاجتماعي مهم
جدا انه يكون اللاعب حاسس انه هو راح يكون
ببيئه حاضنه جيده بالنسبه له هاي الرساله
اللي كان مبارح او اول مبارح النصر
وكريستيانو رونالدو عم بيحاولوا يوصلوها
للعالم ككل اللي مفكر انه مشروع رونالدو
هو النهايه بالنسبه للرياضه السعوديه
وللكره السعوديه وللعجله الاقتصاديه
السعوديه المتعلقه بكره القدم بيكون غلطات
جدا التعاقد مع رونالدو هو بدايه لمرحله
اكبر لتعاقد مع عدد اخر من اللاعبين بكبار
جدا مثل ميسي ربما بوسكيتش ربما سيرجيو
راموس مودريتش اسماء كبيره سمعنا عنا
بالمرحله الماضي وهاي المرحله قد تكون
بدايه لمرحله اخرى ايضا عبر التعاقد مع
لاعبين كبار وهن بعز اداءهم وهذا الامر
الصعب جدا طيب كل هذا الكلام جميل وحلو
والحياه ورديه ورونالدو مبسوط بالسعوديه
والدوري السعودي عم يضم اللاعبين والنجوم
ولكن في تحديات لازم نحكي عنها وفي امور
ايضا قد تعرقل مسيره انتقاله هؤلاء
اللاعبين الى السعوديه اول سبب وقبل كل
شيء لازم نحكي عنه هو حاله رونالدو لما
انتقل السعوديه هل رونالدو لما انتقل من
مانشستر يونايتد الى السعوديه كان بقمه
مجده او كان عم يؤدي بشكل جيد على الاقل
مع مانشستر يونايتد خلال الموسم الحالي
وانتقل انه حب التجربه بالسعوديه وح ب
مثلا انه يخوض تجربه جديده باسيا لا طبعا
البعض ممكن يقول كان في اسباب ماديه وما
الى ذلك وبالتاكيد الماده بتلعب دور ولكن
كان في اسباب اخرى انه رونالدو انتهت
مسيرته باوروبا شعر انه ما عاد له اي مدخل
باوروبا ولا نادي حاب يتعاقد معه لا بي اس
جي لا باير حتى سبورتنج
ومانشستر يونايتد خلص انتهت العلاقه بينهم
بالانترفيو اللي عملها مع بيرسم قبل كاس
العالم لذلك كان خيار الوحيد هو الانتقال
الى اسيا اليوم مودريتش
راموس غيرهم من اللاعبين الكبار ميسي راح
يسالوا حالهم هل انا مرغوب في باوروبا ولا
لا هل انا عندي فرصه ان العب باوروبا ولا
انتهت فرسي باوروبا اذا عنده واحد بالميه
فرصه يلعب باوروبا رح يضلوا ما راح يدخل
على السعوديه مهما كان الثمن ومهما كانت
الفوائد الماديه ومهما كانت التشجيعات او
المشجعات الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه فهذا
تحدي اول بالنسبه
للرياضه السعوديه والقائمين عليها التحدي
الثاني والاخير اللي لازم احكي عنه ايضا
هو مستوى الدوري السعودي نفسه
احنا اليوم بنطلع على الدوري السعودي
بنشوف الهلال النصر الاتحاد هذول الثلاث
فرق هم الفرق المسيطرين هن فرق قويه عندها
جماهير عندها لاعبين مميزين وهن واجهت
الكره السعوديه ولكن ماذا عن بقيه الفرق
بقيه الفرق بالسعوديه لحد الان مش قادره
توصل لمرحله معينه من المستوى اللي يفيد
الانديه الاخرى ويفيد الدور السعودي
ويخليه اكثر تنافسيه ويخليه جاذب بشكل
اكبر للنجوم لانه ما فيك بس تجذب النجوم
عبر فريقين او ثلاث فرق بدورك لازم ترفع
المستوى العام للدوري ترفع الاداء العام
للدوري لحتى اللاعبين يحبوا يجوا لعندك
ويصير دوريك يعني تنافس بشكل اكبر
فصوره كريستيانو رونالدو مضامينها كانت
اكبر من مجرد انه احتفال بيوم التاسيس او
كريستيانو رونالدو مع النصر او ما الى ذلك
لا مضامينها مثل ما حكينا كانت اكبر من
ذلك وهي جزء من مخطط طويل الامد بالنسبه
للكره السعوديه ومثل ما حكينا جيد رونالدو
هي مجرد البدايه لوين راح تمشي الامور
وعلى شو رح يرسم مشروع رونالدو والسعوديه
هذا امر متروك للايام ولكن بالتاكيد لحد
الان المشروع يبدو انه بطريقه للنجاح
هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض الصافره حتى
نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا بالف خير
[تصفيق]